un petit suisse sans les mains
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tiassalé déjà que la date limite de
consommation de tous les aliments qu'on
va utiliser est dépassé depuis très
longtemps donc ne les mangent et pas
voilà je vous lis également dans le
public voilà c'est très simple on va
jouer tous les 3 à ça ce serait ouvre
par exemple aulas des gens un peu
autiste va démarrer doucement il ya des
chocs de vinaigre blanc aura six même
objectif est d'en voir le plus possible
en 30 secondes à chanel mais on va
donner des enchères les on a une vie
aussi après va donner des enchères je
vous le dis chaque fois celui qui aura
la charge un peu hot devra faire le
difficile défi réaliser on mettra de
l'argent de côté bien sûr pour
l'association rêves de gosse image de
nous tenir par les enfants josée très
très moche l'objectif est d'en boire le
plus possible en 30 secondes quand tu
veux le faire 10 n'a pas encore 5 chacun
tu vas être malade
c'est dégueulasse
va revenir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah non alors la poubelle
ils sont mal est la variole d'avoir et
en 30 secondes faire manger jusqu'au
purée on dirait que les olé fins
uniquement sa bouche
ah la la chaque gramme rendre à manger
rapportera 10 euros à la championne
excusez vous qui êtes vous alors moi je
peux pour jeudi voilà dix grammes et
jeudi mois déjà alors je le dis il ya 10
euros par chaque gramme 10 grammes
donc ça fait 100 euros a fait disons
rien du tout en attendant de savoir où
sont les toilettes au premier étage du
coup bien comment 10 g j g 10 grammes
audi g moi j 20 grammes est avec moi en
même temps chez brabus n'est quand même
pas vous dire moi je suis blindé les
abus heureusement comme ça donc quand tu
dis monaco mc 10 grammes des vagues
ravaler ses pas beaucoup ah non moi je
te laisse là toutes les semaines sont
bien trouvés g après le doigt c'est donc
30 g ça ferait quand de gamme saffré 30
euros cette connerie c'est pas beaucoup
30 euros tu vas mal croissant mais
comment est trop lourd comme enjeu s'est
passé ton émission au non en fait c'est
quand ça va toucher d'abord un pote à la
sister
nature et fait rimer on est d'accord en
plus sur la tête de ma mère la purée mon
frère pommes de terre en 1802 entier
alors tu te fais attention pour ce
nouveau défi bas de valloire ces deux
gars s'est fait percer le plus bref
possible sur la tête
en seulement dix secondes chacun casse
et offrira 500 euros à l'association
jeudi sur la tête mais je peux dire non
tu peux dire merci
on peut sans casser je sais pas mais non
mais toi tu dois y aller comme ça la
tête dans les épaules des guillemets
vous ou un toit 1 1
quoi un bon mois 1 1 ben oui enfin
alors deux tu dis pas d'où tu me jeu
mais hadji 3 et tous
c'est de plonger de bercy c'était une
piscine la tête dedans théorie non mais
tu vas te faire mal terna est ce qu'en
fait tu as we pray outre ya comme ça
c'est moins drôle je vais faire alors
dans son chrono ses encours seconde je
dois en faire 10 attention le record je
rappelle cette année aux landes et qu'il
a combien ces huit en 30 secondes nous
renforcions sur trois deux un non mais
attendez on attend l'arrivée
[Applaudissements]
en 2007 son commencement masqué on et il
m'a dit mika le film sort demain
tiens toi bien jusqu'à la fin pas
d'armageddon attention derrière défi
dernier défi en 2007 à la c il va se
faire celui-ci
[Applaudissements]
leïla
ça
et
j'ai lu ici ou pas peut faire mal au
public attention en toi
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est trop normal oui cas d'accord on
arrête on aller s'il vous plaît la
réplique à savoir avec mika on arrête
c'est à vue c'est lui franchement ça
fait double élection des devinettes les
séries alors attention on a tout le
public qui a des petits suisses
regardent épargnant tous ces données
c'est le jeu vous allez tous lancés ça
j'adore ça comme ça six employés nous
nous rejoignons n'étant dirait chamboule
tout ça sort mercredi
et ce avec très très simple tout le
public va jeter son petit suisse à mon
top où ils vont le jeter sur moi
oh non pardonnez moi
pour sa pente est contré face à la
suisse qui m'a touché ces 100 euros tu
as c'est bon tu venir à côté de moi je
je crois que non je ne suis pas très fan
de ça il est des matins je préfère les
yaourts attention à la fois 2 attention
je suis très cinéma 3d un petit suisse
sans les mains
[Applaudissements]
brad pitt
oblige on en convient pour l'association
tous les cherry se faisait avant
l'assemblée balle polish découvert 18
tonnes d'argent
[Applaudissements]